[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان العرب القدماء يقسمون حراره الصيف الى
قسمين صيف وقيظ الصيف بدايه الحرف والقيض
شده الحر وكانوا يطلقون على الصيفه ربيعا
ومنه قولهم الصيفه ضيعتي اللبن فلا تكثر
الالبان الا في موسم الربيع وعلامه ذلك
وامارته حاجه المزروعات الى سقيا ويعرفون
ذلك بمقارنه القمر لاشهر نجوم السماء اللي
هي اثريا في اليوم الاول من الشهر الهجري
وقالوا قران حادي على الماء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعامه قسموا الصيف على اربعه مواسم كنت
تريا اربعين يوما مربعانيه القيظ اربع هنا
يوما تتحث القير 26 يوما جمره القير 26
يوما وبعدها يدخل علينا موسم سهيل فيا
صاحبي رحلي دنى الموت فنزيلا برابيه اني
مقيم ليالي يا اقيم علي اليوم او بعض ليله
ولا تعجلان قد تبين ما بي اقول لاصحاب
يرفعوني فانني يقر بعيني عن سهيل بداليا
[موسيقى]